stop the auto theft that has run rampant
under this prime minister he's now
throwing a cape over his back claiming
that he's the hero on auto theft but
it's actually tripled in Toronto and
it's up by 100% in Montreal after he
brought in Catch and Release and house
arrest for car thieves and after his
incompetence allowed our ports to spin
out of control and our cars to be
exported to overseas crime and Terror
networks why doesn't he reverse his
policies instead of another
meeting the right honorable prime
minister Mr Speaker this is a serious
situation Canadians are concerned about
this uh and the conservative leader just
chooses to whip out his empty slogans
and continue uh to blame everyone while
we're getting to work we're pulling
together stakeholders and leaders from
across the government uh to look at from
across governments to look at uh what
more we can do we've had we've seen
successes cbsa agents have intercepted
over 1, 1600 stolen cars uh last year in
2023 but there's more to do we're going
to continue to make uh the steady uh
work and Investments necessary to keep
Canadians safe and to keep crime
Down The Honorable leader of the
opposition keep crime down crime is way
up violent crime is up 40% under this
prime minister and today he held he had
his ministers hold a big press
conference as their solution and in it
they put out a press release that said
and I quote in 2022 a approximately
9,600 Vehicles were stolen in the
Toronto area alone representing a 300%
increase since
2015 end quote what happened in
2015 what happened I know he happened Mr
Speaker how can we make him unhappen and
stop the
crime the right honorable prime minister
speaker in 2015 Steven Harper presented
a budget that had slashed funds for
policing slashed funds uh for cbsa
officers a slash funding for Veterans
Affairs services and we were there to
clean up the mess to cut taxes for the
wealthiest 1% lower them for the middle
class to support families to start
moving forward on gun control in real
ways while the conservatives cozy up to
the American Gun lobbies we contined to
step up and keeping Canadians safe let
him bring assault weapons back to our
streets we'll keep Canadians
safe The Honorable leader of the
opposition wow is he ever losing control
of
himself oh my goodness screaming and
hollering like that Mr Speaker it's his
press release that says that in
Toronto Auto thefts are Up 3 100% since
he took office his solution is to hold a
summit he held a summit on food prices
food prices went up he held a summit on
housing housing costs doubled how much
is crime going to rise after all the big
wigs go to his
Summit the right honorable prime
minister speaker the leader of the
opposition has trouble believing that we
would actually include
facts in our press release something he
and the Harper government never did for
years yes Mr Speaker there is a real
challenge around auto theft in this
country and our solution is to roll up
our sleeves pull together Partners from
across the country and get to solving it
his solution throw his hands up in the
air Blame A a raft of of political
attacks on us and continue to see uh
that he's not putting forward any real
solu ions Mr
Speaker